hey cinephiles welcome to another movie
clips review this is js and i'm james
and today we're talking about the raid 2
baron doll um so the title hints that
this is a sequel
back in 2011 the raid redemption came
out
and by my estimation action films were
never the same again i felt that that
movie completely raised the bar
absolutely and i didn't know how they
were possibly going to top it the same
cast and crew has reunited more or less
for the raid too and
i just think everything has been taken
to the next level i mean they they
turned it to 11 for the raid it seemed
like so i mean now we're who knows where
that is yeah it's broken yeah
well just general thoughts what do you
think about this film i loved it um i
had seen uh the raid the first one for
the first time like two months ago
basically because i heard that this one
was so good out of sundance yeah i was
like i have to see the raid too i need
to watch this so let me get caught up
and then i i liked the first one quite a
bit but then this one just blew me away
yeah amazing uh amazing amazing action
sequences i love the story as well so
completely blown away yeah i mean the
first one had a very simple concept it
was it was pretty much in real time and
it was basically this
siege on an apartment tower that's been
taken over by this crime lord
essentially but this next film it it
picks up like two hours after the first
film left off but then it's also just
this huge like
it's an epic story it is basically about
the crime syndicate in jakarta this is
rama and so basically they're cleaning
up the situation from the first film and
then he's gonna go undercover into this
crime family to basically figure out all
the corrupt police force that's in
jakarta at that time
it's a really sprawling story in fact it
reminds me of movies like infernal
affairs which scorsese
remade it to the departed uh new world
the korean actually filmed from last
year as well yeah but yeah this is it's
just bigger in scope and i think there's
a lot of build-up mm-hmm yeah
yeah they set the stage pretty well at
the beginning and yeah you're right it's
basically the opposite of the first one
so the first one you know real time one
location basically and then this one uh
spans years yeah that's right literally
does and it's just it just only gets
bigger yeah and in fact fans of the
first film might be a little concerned
going in because it's something like the
first half hour of this not a lot of
action almost little to none right um
but it's it's all of this just it's
really a slow burn to what i think is
just one of the most remarkable
sequences in modern film which is this
prison yard scrambled yeah and i mean
it's a rainstorm has just finished
everything's muddy yeah and then all of
these inmates and the guards just get
into this all-out war and it's fantastic
it's brutal yeah there's like guys
picking up rocks and slamming it on
another guy's head and people ripping
each other's faces apart yeah from the
job yeah this is an incredibly violent
movie yeah it really is really
especially that fight sequence was the
most violent for me okay it was just
like crazy phones being broken you know
knives going everywhere and it was just
and you saw this in the theater right it
did what was the audience reaction like
uh a lot of uh
not oohs and odds but you know
cringes yeah you could hear the cringes
happening just people being like oh yeah
and i was doing it too so it's a very
visceral reaction for the audience and
it's a lot of fun i mean some people are
going to be turning away and they'll be
squeamish but if you can get it through
that prison york fight i think you're
going to be yeah you're okay yeah if you
can make it through there it doesn't get
much more brutal than that even but it
you know it's still pretty good it
definitely ratchets it up um i i just
got to say there's there's probably like
a dozen set pieces with these gorgeously
choreographed fight scenes throughout
the movie yeah um just a few of my
favorite there's one in a porn den
that's especially memorable
in fact if you saw gareth evans sequence
from vhs2 there's actually a cameo from
one of the actors in there which is
really nice that's cool um uh other ones
the hammer girl and yeah baseball bat
boy two favorite characters yeah they're
amazing i mean you know how the first
raid was kind of like a video game and
it's very simple plot yeah these
characters are almost like mini bosses
right that he has to eventually face
down yeah um so yeah there's a this
really brutal fight on the subway that
takes place um
just lots and lots of memorable stuff
going on like i can't wait to flip
through the scene selections on the
blu-ray just because i know each one is
going to be oh i know exactly what this
scene is yeah and this movie is two and
a half hours long it's so long and
there's so much in it that i can barely
remember what happens in the middle
there's so much i really just remember
the end like all the fight scenes there
because those are so great yeah but
there's so much stuff that happens
throughout
and and they really did a well job of
just like okay we're gonna be like
talking about the impact of what we just
watched in an action sequence yeah and
how that relates to all the characters
at large
in the first film i would say they were
martial artists first and foremost after
second yeah this time around there's
some people there who are legitimately
fine actors and they are giving solid
work yeah um so yeah i i cannot
recommend the raid 2 enough it is my
favorite film of the year so far same
with me same with me
what i enjoyed about it if you like kill
bill for me this was if you took volume
one and volume two and then made one
movie out of them because it has the
ultra violence of volume one with the
compelling drama of volume two so if you
mix them together yeah and it was just
the perfect match for me that's a great
way to put it it is the whole bloody
affair really so
the raid 2 guys you got to see it first
movie clips this is js and i'm james